julia was geht hier ist max und herzlich
willkommen zur nächsten folge
minecraft nero sozusagen
ja ich glaube ich gehe jetzt los zum
tanzen
ich habe zwar ende letzter erfolg fast
komplett anderes gesagt und ist schon
wieder mitten in der nacht jetzt aber
ich will einfach mal action und ich
glaube ihr wollt auch action also ich
hatte jetzt nur ein paar wenige folgen
gebaut aber irgendwie minecraft muss
action für mich haben also an sonst ist
alles irgendwie nicht so lustig okay so
wir schauen erst mal aber das gewachsen
ist und richtig auf action wie wir sind
gehen wir diesen usa richtig auf die
schnauze hauen und holen uns sein
ein leckeres obst fleisch war hier dass
das ist die quelle des schreckens hier
die kennen wir schon hieß es nichts
gewachsen
das heißt mal wieder ab oben nach oben
ins in unseren unterschlupf und es wird
auch schon wieder tag leute ich verliere
so schnell essen haben wir das irgendwie
noch zusätzlich auf hartz gestellt oder
so dass man kultur vergibt nur einheit
hunger balken und ich freue mich die
ganze zeit so als wäre etwas richtig
cooles das hier voll schlecht wird immer
noch besser als so richtig schlecht zu
machen kann man schon sagen wir sind
eigentlich zu wertvollen sie einfach zu
essen
ich kann mir schon die hälfte mitnehmen
ferner zum boot gehen
ich habe jetzt großen stil sachen
angepflanzt
deshalb dürfte es passen eigentlich wenn
ich mir da noch ein bisschen was nehme
so pfeil bogen nähe brauche ich
wahrscheinlich nicht bei der expedition
ihr wisst ja vielleicht noch welchen
dungeon nicht mehr vor knüpfen will
und zwar den den ich gefunden habe als
ich auf der suche nach einem etwa die
ich dann beim tauschen bekommen habe mit
mit diesem dorfbewohner das hier gar
nicht allzu weit von hier da dürfen wir
so ein naja 23 minuten hin gelaufen sein
der atlas hat dass sie also noch drin
den habe ich zum glück davor abgelegt
habe bevor ich die 1000 mahle gestorben
bin seht ihr da unten ist das dorf so
als village eingezeichnet ist echt ein
geiles ding der atlas muss ich sagen
kann man auf jeden fall gebrauchen so
das schiff dürfte jetzt hier vorne sein
genau wird dann schnappen wir uns ja
noch ein paar millionen zu mir wirklich
sehr leid aber es muss halt einfach muss
halt ein bisschen das passieren so gut
die hälfte von der melodie ich jetzt
abbaut welche auch einfach nochmals
pflanzen habe ich gerade beschlossen und
das was jetzt hier abbau pflanze ich mal
oben ans weizenfeld noch an weil auf
jeden fall schon jemanden eine ähnliche
idee und hat sich irgendeine stadt
versorgen was das essen angeht kümmern
wollen
und hier ist gerade richtig schön ist
mut sage ich wahrscheinlich irgendwie so
40 fps hat oder so aber so bin ich halt
irgendwie echt nicht mehr gewöhnt
seitdem ich soviel nero spiele weil zeit
einfach wir wie sau liegt kann man sagen
was man will so das einzige was ich
hoffe es ist dass ich nicht mehr so
ewigen opengl habe wenn ich gerade
wirklich in gefahr
also wenn ich gerade vor irgendeinem
mega boss stehe so der ok das ist echt
nicht mehr viel mit kraft vor
irgendeinem heftige boss oder sowas
stehe der mich halt einfach total
schnell zerstören würde
und da habe ich einfach angst dass sich
dann irgendwie auch ein bisschen auf dem
server stehen bleiben mich halt aber
nicht bewegen kann welcher geklickt
werde und dass ich dann halt einfach
zerstört werde
sehr unschön
stories gerettet gar keine knochen
gedroppt vielleicht springt ja auch
einfach mal ein bisschen weniger und
denen hast du zu sagen ist jetzt jemand
gestorben
wie wärs denn der stamm
normalerweise sagt ist doch da was oder
wenn rechtzeitig drauf marschiert dann
grabstein von blabla ich kurz davor sein
okay dann keine ahnung viel aber solche
sicherheitshalber auf dem friedhof
stellen aber die person wird dann
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr erfahren habe
absolut keine ahnung wer das hier
gewesen sein könnte der hier gestorben
ist aber es ist auf jeden fall schauen
wir nicht falsch wenn wir uns hier
beteiligen und auch ein paar sachen
platzieren und am wasser ist eigentlich
auch gar nicht falsch mitzunehmen oder
weil jemand richtig netter unterwegs das
sieht richtig irgendwie nach dem und
stege aus ich will sicher dass sie mir
in wassereimer geben wollen
wer auch immer das ist ich bin ein
richtiger die ich glaube bei jedem
irgendwie immer so ein bisschen was und
am ende ist es dann doch gar nicht so
wenig mir leid leute in das sieht dann
geht in mein haus und nehmt euch
irgendwas ist ihr braucht wer auch immer
das jetzt gerade war so das sollte ja
auch noch an pflanzen
das hält uns hier gerade ein bisschen
auf aber wir haben kompletten sandstrand
wenn man richtig sicher dass man auf
sand keine melonen anbauen kann weil ich
hier kann man nicht einfach
herr um 11 stressig man kann ich gar
keine meloni anbauen
aber oben am wasser wahrscheinlich oder
einfach anfällt kann man melonen anbauen
wo vor allem mal verliert so unheimlich
schnell essen ich weiß dass ich das
gerade schon zum tausendsten mal sage
aber es schockiert mich einfach total
so nimmt das schockiert mich total wie
schnell man hier das essen verliert weiß
einfach keine ahnung die ersten folge
ist genau richtig gemacht dass mir hat
einfach richtig gemacht dass er dabei
weiter gelaufen ist weiß nicht genau
aber in den ersten folgen hatte ich mir
das ganze essen mitgenommen
ich will aber jetzt nicht so rum
schleichen die ganze zeit ich werde
schon mal schon mal sprinten ihrem
richtigen weg sondern die richtung genau
so ich war schon ein bisschen springen
weil ich halt einfach keine zeit so viel
zeit damit zu verlieren und das ist
irgendwie auch durch wie viele sind das
drei stück aber die laufen
wahrscheinlich alle runter in die lava
so dumm wie die hier sind so packe ich
drei stück ich denke schon
sozusagen ich jetzt selbst nicht dumm
bin und die lava falle soll ich lache
über die und dann passiert
wahrscheinlich selbst habe ich mich
kennen
stressig wenn es wenn es so viele sind
dann ist es schon ein bisschen tag muss
ich sagen ich glaube es sind dafür sechs
usa genau die ich jetzt druck bekommen
habe dann war es mir das ganze auf jeden
fall wert weil es gibt das gibt gekocht
auf jeden fall war
gekocht zumindest gibt es schon mal mehr
als alles andere hier wo ich mich echt
mal aufpassen ich später wieder voll wie
viel schaden machen die mir mit ihren
strahlen das ist das problem wenn man so
wenig essen hat da muss man die ganze
zeit gucken dass also wenn man etwas so
wenig regeneriert besser gesagt schon
die ganze zeit gucken dass man irgendwie
regierungsfähig ist ist schon was ich
meine denke ich ich bin nach wie vor auf
dem richtigen weg und schilder werden
wir wahrscheinlich eher keine brauchen
so ich habe auch jetzt gar nicht noch
mal extra gecheckt ob ich etwas
wertvolles dabei habe aber was soll ich
schon groß wert weil das haben
man muss vor häufig gestorben ich sehe
es auch in meinem inventar nix dem blatt
habe ich auf jeden fall in der truhe und
der ist ja wirklich das übt das
wertvollste eigentlich weiß ich was ich
besitze zurzeit mitteilt der rüstung und
dem schwert was ich damit zumindest die
rüstung mit patrick c für bekommen habe
so unfähig hat mich letztens getötet
halten wird es irgendwie also ist so
heftig die monster sind eigentlich alle
relativ stark aber sobald du dann das
skript hast was du zumindest wenn du mit
petr in der stadt bist relativ schnell
bekommst ist irgendwie alles so
entspannt so auch sehr schön ich dass
echtes fleisch kann kann usa
das kann hier auf jeden fall mal beraten
jetzt so und ich habe nicht die richtung
verlieren wir so ein bisschen rooftop
chillen kopplin ist da unten
es gibt hier auch irgendwo so ausflüge
unten
ich werde hier angegriffen von opel es
gibt hier auch weiß gar nicht was ich
sagen wollte leute es ist manchmal echt
schwierig hier in euro beziehungsweise
ich bin irgendwie nicht so ultra viertel
das vergifte mich wahrscheinlich welche
blumen die hier in der nähe stehen so
wie ich das smartpad kenne man weiß nie
was passiert
die auch schön aus die droppen portal
steine und diese droppen kommen meistens
nicht alleine tritt meistens nicht
alleine auf eigentlich diese kleinen
busche nanu habe hier war schon mal
jemand schenkt war ich selbst war
wahrscheinlich gleich selbst als sehr
schön gewesen erst noch ein portal stein
zu bekommen nennt man immer schön unser
portal geschmissen und dann wäre ich
vielleicht auch das erste mal
irgendwohin gefahren
vielleicht war so jemand anders schon in
dem bei dem ort wo das mich hin geführt
hätte oh ja da ist ein händler
mega cool wie und das einzige was der
branche handelt animas ton
man habe ich mich schon gefreut einmal
ein händler zu finden und dann ist es so
ein lappen
nichtsdestotrotz weiß irgendwann das mal
braucht baue ich den typen hier mal ein
ist glaube ich nicht falsch wenn man ja
die zur verfügung hat wenn man sie
irgendwann mal brauchen sollte wo es
wieder so ein kleines ding kommt ob
jetzt job jetzt soja mais wir haben rems
thorn prikker sehr schön cool dann haben
wir ihn auf jeden fall schon mal zwei
stück sogar direkt
noch weniger anlass zu sterben ich werde
ihn vielleicht einfach in einer kiste
sichern gleich wo sich den anhalt
irgendjemand aus der stadt holen kann
falls ich sterben sollte man muss
wirklich vorkehrungen treffen leute aber
die kiste platziere ich wahrscheinlich
am besten am eingang vom vom dungeon da
werde ich glaube ich am besten beraten
sein
ich glaube die dimension für kärcher ist
nicht eine der einfachsten okay das
essen geht zugrunde und wie bist du
nicht eine der einfachsten und es werde
schon wieder nacht da ist es jetzt
ausnahmsweise mal guten dungeon zu sein
weil bei nacht zählt ja eigentlich
wirklich primär nur in dach über dem
kopf zu haben
hier gibt es anscheinend noch jede menge
essen jede menge schweine
es könnte also nicht besser sein
also als an bedingungen um in den
dungeon reinzugehen
es können keine besseren bedingungen
herrschen so und man vernünftigen
deutschen satz zu formulieren so in
fleisch
ich bin ein paar war okay alles klar
wir sind bei zwölf minuten die reise zum
dorf selbst hat jetzt nicht so lange
gedauert und hier stand auch ein bett
drin oder hatte ich das mal letzten mal
mitgenommen das bett legen wir haben
besonderen gutes gefühl dass ich
oregon heißt das heißt ich habe die
ganze nacht wo alles so perfekt das ist
so perfekt für den dungeon ist die ganze
nacht lang stärke okay das heißt ich
werde jetzt ganz schnell eine truhe hier
bauen und der dungeon eingang war hier
vorne und vor dem dungeon eingang
platziere ich dann dass das ding power
unit es ist so kalt dass diese
begeistert bin wird ich glaube nicht
dass euch das stört wenig begeisterten
und da kann es noch besser wir wollen
euch ein bett also zumindest sich in
dieser nacht dieser nacht ist es das
beste was uns passieren kann kein bett
zu haben weil wir haben die ganze nacht
über stärke das ist diese dieses ehre
von event vor aber es kann warten comet
hierunter city as one hit [ __ ] [ __ ]
reihen der rheiner leute einfach nur
rein hier so so erstmal das hier in ruhe
platzieren gut und dann platzieren wir
hier jetzt die truhe mal langte es langt
anscheinend nicht ganz für die frühe
nochmal einen abbauen von den sachen so
und packender die stones reihen dass wir
zumindest sicher gehen können dass
jemand aus unserer aus unserer stadt
später die möglichkeit hat nach brescia
zu gehen so theaters bringen wir
wahrscheinlich später auch sogar noch
was sodann muss ich mir eigentlich noch
ein bisschen korbel abbauen damit ich
was ist eigentlich schade dass ich jetzt
nicht durchstarten kann
aber ich brauche noch ein bisschen
korbel dass ich mit meinem fleisch
gleich brennen kann weil kombi dürfte es
da unten auch noch zu genüge geben
ich baue mir nur ghana den ofen
brüssel treffen wir den ofen und dann
geht dann rasch ist jetzt unten rein in
den in den dungeon nervös natürlich
aufpassen dass diese ganzen pressure
plate geschichten und so aber ich glaube
ich werde die erste teil ist wäre ich
direkt außen vor lassen weil ich mein
wert zu halten braucht die ich hoffe nur
dass direkt die nächste darunter ist
aber in der regel findet man wenn man
sie einfach nur störe unterbaut noch
eine andere etage so dass auch schon die
nächste perfekt hat mir also glück
gehabt so und ich glaube ab jetzt müssen
wir einfach mal laufen also mich
interessieren nur die untersten beiden
etagen direkt der abgang zur nächsten
wieder interessiert nur die untersten
beiden weil man da halt die besten
sachen kriegt also dieses meding und
sowas ist natürlich vollkommen okay und
vielleicht finden wir sogar schnell
unsere unsere eigene kleine so sorry
spanier ist jetzt nicht so major dass
man den irgendwie brauchen würde
was wollte ich gerade sagen vielleicht
finden wir ja sogar unsere eigene gas
träne hinter vorn ist schon ok wo kommt
der kollege her eigentlich dürfen durch
die spanner weg sein von oben
ok so ein bisschen guckt kann nicht
schaden
es ist einfach sooo geil mit der stärke
wie du einfach alles was in die quere
kommt one hit ist so arg dass nehmen
jetzt mit wieder ein bisschen cook talk
und sobald fünf mal ein bisschen intense
wird dann stellen wir uns das ding
wieder auf wir haben jetzt noch fünf
minuten in der zeit möchte ich
eigentlich gerne ein bisschen was
schaffen
also weg damit okay das ist gar nicht so
ein grabstein ding gewesen wie ich
gehofft hatte aber hier vorne science
okay das heißt möglichst schnell die
spanne infizieren
wo die sich dahinter befinden uns
zurzeit 1 bonner es weg sonders der
nächste
es gibt anscheinend noch einmal da oben
ist halt was runter gefallen oder er ist
einfach nur brandon davis band so und
sieht gut aus
randa braucht man nicht ist sehr nice
als unnötig oder stehen das papier hier
und da sind wir hier vereines clay
brauchen wir auch nicht so wirklich
historischen naja also selbst im pvp
später wird es glaube ich nicht so
das sein was wir unbedingt brauchen so
einen weg mit forschen besser will ich
sagen
gehen wir mal ab weiter und sehen zu
dass wir noch irgendwie einen weiteren
abgang finden aber das dürfte ja direkt
hier vorne sein
solche runter wir haben auf jeden fall
noch die ganze nacht stärke das wäre so
optimal wenn wir diesen diese diesem
netter teil finden von von von dem
abgang namen jack sage ich nicht nein
auf jeden fall wieder eine negative
forschen sagt auf jeden fall nein
aufpassen ist das saphir nee das ist
einfach kind da geht schon direkt zum
nächsten teil runter ich gucke mal ganz
kurz oben ob sie noch eine kiste geht
gibt also mehr das leben ein bisschen
gefährlich aus dass auch also ich habe
jetzt noch nicht so super geile sachen
irgendwie gesehen auf der auf der höhe
auf der etage
deshalb würde ich fast einfach mal durch
waschen und zu zur nächsten runter gehen
so her damit
xp kostenlose xp immer nah ist ich darf
alles bonner abbauen
das sicherheits später noch ein bisschen
was kriege
so keine gast also die du dir die sachen
die man hier finden sind echt schwach ok
davon gibt es immer noch ein paar kisten
drin dieses spinnen leben zeigt das war
ich mal ab ich wäre eigentlich nur gas
trainer was anderes interessiert mich
gar nicht so und hier gibt es wie gesagt
immer eigentlich zwei kisten drin
ja okay dass sie eine brauche ich nicht
und hier ist rang vier das ist schon gut
für 143 mining für tig weiß ich nicht
genau was das bedeutet aber ich glaube
es ist ja bis jetzt alles nicht so gut
als dass sich das lohnen würde ich werde
jetzt einmal zurückgehen und noch mal
die andere etage auschecken
wir haben wirklich glück mit der mit der
stärke die wir die ganze nacht haben
dass er bin ich traurig wenn es die
nacht vorbei geht
bogen damit ist klar so hier zurück und
da geht es runter war da ist das
gefährlich wenn feuerwehr war unter
gefallen in die höhle ok chefs beider
abbauen abbauen können wir schönes drin
sagt man nicht nein
so und jetzt geht es auch mal wieder was
zu essen ich bin jetzt so richtig
motiviert muss ich sagen dass merkel
wahrscheinlich auch schon durch die
tatsache dass sie einfach glück haben ja
einfach glück warum warum habe ich jetzt
irgend welchen effekt
da ist jetzt alles noch nicht so geil
was wir finden auch die können einfach
durch waschen aber es macht macht sinn
das sind immerhin spinnen aber trotzdem
ist das irgendwie ein bisschen hippie
wenn ihr einfach so durch gesprintet
kommen die viecher stirbst du mal bitte
so auch auf jeden fall die rüstung im
blick halten weil wenn die kaputt geht
dann aber prost mahlzeit leute es gibt
eigentlich immer zwei also immer 22
kisten habe ich das immer so gesehen
gibt es hier schönes hinten da geht in
die richtung geht anscheinend der dann
schon weiter wobei der kann in zwei
richtungen weiter gehen so affig dieses
spiel verlieren einfach nur zeitwert vor
der zeit wertvolle zeit mit dem es trenc
perfekt
ich dachte das wäre vielleicht schon
schon der nada teil davon haben wir ein
bisschen limit gold ja alles ganz schick
aber lohnt sich für mich nicht wirklich
deshalb zurück zu gehen
es gilt jetzt hier weiter durch zu
waschen
wir sind die fackeln feinschnitt an rest
over night das jetzt nicht bis jetzt
nicht wahr
in dem moment wo ich den abgang zum
netter sehe es erstens unsere folge
vorbei und zweitens der strength effekt
weg und da muss ich mir merken leute war
noch ein entspannter den brauche ich
absolut leute ich nehme es noch eine
folge auf nur eine machen jetzt direkt
im anschluss das war es von heute macht
es gut bis zum nächsten mal schießt